we have to talk to her first of all you
look amazing Thank You cyma I when I
talked to her at the Grammy Museum you
were very humble about what a nomination
would mean but now you're a winner
how does it feel crazy I just honestly I
still feel like I'm like flirting on a
cloud I still can't quite believe it
it's still so surreal
I'm gonna need a couple days to process
it and honestly I only just found out
and I'm still it's taken me a second I'm
surprised you still have your makeup
together because you cried during the
love no I was just saying in my last
interview I my makeup is like literally
slowly fading away at the end because my
eyes are watering and I'm really trying
to hold it together just just wanna do
the red carpet and then I don't care I
think you also got to perform it and
you're up for Best New Artist I mean how
does this all feel in this moment just
surreal so she has a British artist to
be here it means the absolute well to me
I can't believe it bring the entire
family because I know you guys roll deep
we do roll deep I've only brought my
parents this time my boyfriend is up
well congratulations good luck to you
I'm rooting for you girl
[Music]